COUNTRY RESPOND TO THE SOURCE OF
THIS CORRUPTION, THAT IS CHINA’S
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP?
HERE NOW WITH REACTION, ARKANSAS
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
YOU WENT OUT EARLY ON THIS.
I REMEMBER WATCHING AND I’M
LOOKING AT HIM LISTENING, I’VE
ALWAYS VIEWED YOU AS VERY
CREDIBLE.
I WASN’T SURE OF IT ALL AND DID
MY OWN INVESTIGATIVE WORK.
I DIDN’T HAVE A DEFINITIVE
ANSWER AND I STILL DON’T BUT IN
LISTENING TO WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
AND WHAT HE’S SAYING, WHERE DO
YOU THINK THE STORY LEADS?
>> SEAN SINCE JANUARY I HAVE
SAID IT SEEMS TO BE HIGHLY
COINCIDENTAL THAT THIS VERY
CONTAGIOUS VIRUS ORIGINATED JUST
A FEW HUNDRED YARDS OR MAYBE A
COUPLE OF MILES FROM
LABORATORIES WHERE THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY RESEARCHERS
CORONAVIRUS IS.
BRETT BEARS REPORTING TONIGHT
SHOWS THAT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY
SINGLE DEATH, EVERY JOB LOST,
EVERY RETIREMENT NEST EGG LOST
FROM THIS CORONAVIRUS.
AND XI JINPING AND HIS CHINESE
COMMUNIST APPARATCHIKS MUST BE
MADE TO PAY THE PRICE IF THAT
TURNS OUT TO BE TRUE.
>> Sean: WHILE THEY CERTAINLY
UPHOLD A LOT OF AMERICA’S DEBT.
THIS IN AN AREA WHERE WE COULD
PERHAPS GET COMPENSATION?
>> WE CAN EXAMINE THAT AREA.
I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE THE
AMERICAN COURTS OPEN FOR
LAWSUITS AGAINST CHINESE
COMMUNIST LEADERS.
I HAVE LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
MODIFY THE FOREIGN SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITIES ACT TO DO JUST THAT.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN TO
SEE A MASSIVE SHIFT OF
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY OUT OF
CHINA AND BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES, OR AT LEAST A
FRIENDLY ALLIED COUNTRY WHICH
WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO THE
CHINESE ECONOMY.
BUT JUST IMAGINE, NOT JUST IN
AMERICA BUT ALL AROUND THE WORLD
THE DEMANDS FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CONSEQUENCES ON THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY AND A CHAIRMAN
G.
IF IT TURNS OUT THE CHINESE
NEGLIGENCE AND THEN CHINESE
CORRUPTION AND TREACHERY WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR UNLEASHING THIS
PANDEMIC ON THE WORLD.
>> Sean: IF HIS REPORT BEARS
OUT AS YOU SAID, AND I HAVE NO
REASON TO DOUBT THAT IT WILL
LOOK AT IT CERTAINLY SPEAKS
VOLUMES.
WE WEREN’T ALLOWING TRAVEL FROM
WUHAN TO ANY OTHER AREA INC.
CHINA BUT THEY WERE PERFECTLY
WILLING TO LET PEOPLE IN WUHAN